(phone notification)
- Five minutes?
Ugh!
I hope it's not a hybrid.
(hip hop music and
car horn honking)
- Well, look who it is.
- Hey, Kumail.
What are you doing?
I'm waiting for my car.
- Here it is. Hop in.
I just detailed this puppy.
- Really? Yeah?
- Yeah!
Got a new air freshener,
just for you.
- Yeah, smells like the mall.
- Yeah.
- Why are you my driver?
- Oh, it's gorilla
marketing, you know?
They thought this was
the most efficient way
to get the word out
about our movie.
Go see The Big Sick!
I'm kidding.
You already know about it.
- Okay, well--
Hey, at least you don't gotta
do morning radio, right?
- Yeah.
You know what I miss
about making our movie?
- Getting paid to
nap in the trailer?
- The immediate feedback
on my personality.
- Uh huh.
- Are you in a rush?
- I am.
- Aren't we all?
I wanna be a father,
but I think I'd be
better as a cool uncle,
you know what I mean?
He wears no pants.
He lives in the basement.
He doesn't have a job.
Nobody cares.
He's the cool,
yet slightly
misunderstood uncle.
- Okay. You doing bits?
What's going on?
- No, these are just
my unscripted thoughts
on family dynamics.
You know, cool uncle.
You go to him if
you need a condom.
This guy knows what
I'm talking about.
- Who? What guy?
- Speaking of driving,
you know what drives me batty?
- Oh, god.
- Is when my mom
calls and she's like,
hey, it's mom.
- I wish I had headphones.
- Yes, I know who you are.
I recognize your voice
from yelling at me
to move out of the basement.
- Is this what you're doing?
Trapping people and forcing
your comedy on them?
- No.
Just like, you know,
really cool comedians
whose opinions I value.
- Oh.
- This guy knows
what I'm talking about, right?
- What guy?
There's no guy.
- What else is going on?
Oh, how--
- Okay, what are we doing?
Why aren't we moving?
- Oh, I'm completely out of gas.
Air conditioner and hair
conditioner sound the same,
but they're totally different.
No one's like,
turn on the hair conditioner.
- That joke's a four.
- Four out of what?
Ten?
Five?
Four?
You know, mint's a
funny word, right?
Like, you could say
something's mint condition,
but that don't mean
it smells good.
That's a keeper.
- [Emily] This was fun.
- Wait, we haven't
even had sex again yet.
- I'm just not
that kind of girl.
I only have sex once
on the first date.
I'm just gonna call an Uber.
(phone beeping)
- Your travel will be ready
as soon as he puts on his pants.
♪ Is your bed made?
♪ Is your sweater on?
- Watch and learn, bhai.
Ooh, close!
- I have to tell
you something, bhai.
I've been dating this girl.
She's white.
- A white girl?
- Shh, okay.
You can't look like you
and yell white girl.
It's okay.
We hate terrorists.
(doorbell)
- I wonder who that could be.
- I'm guessing it's a young,
single Pakistani woman.
- This is Zubeida.
- For your files.
Your X-files.
That's your favorite show?
The truth is out there!
(awkward laughing)
- Are you judging
Pakistan's Next Top Model?
- You know how we have arranged
marriage in my culture?
- Oh, my god.
I'm so stupid.
Can you imagine a world
in which we end up together.
- I don't know.
- I'm looking for
Emily Gardiner.
She was checked in tonight.
- There's an infection.
We put her in a
medically-induced coma.
- Coma?
- You should call her family.
- Thank you, Kumail.
We're gonna handle
things from here.
- I think I'm just
gonna wait anyway.
- You guys broke up.
I'm not sure why you're here.
- I'm just gonna
stay for a second.
Is this seat--
Okay.
(dramatic music)
Is that lady still
looking at me?
- So, nine eleven--
I've always wanted to
have a conversation with people.
- You've never talked to
people about nine eleven?
♪ I'm still standing
- Wanna do anything?
You got any Poli Games?
- No, I've never--
- You ever play
You Can't Rhyme It?
You try to find to find a word
that nobody can rhyme.
- Okay.
Stonehenge.
- Yeah, see.
You would win.
♪ If you go there
♪ Go with me.
- I think I screwed
up with your daughter.
- Yeah, you did.
♪ Won't you take me
♪ Take me, please
- Let me give you
some advice, Kumail.
Love isn't easy.
That's why they call it love.
- I don't really get that.
- I know.
I thought I could just
start saying something
and something smart
would come out.
(wild honey by U2)